okay so on this video we're going to
discuss antibiotic resistance so let's
get started
so first of all you know what are
antibiotics well they're medicines they
are medicines that are used to fight
bacterial infections in the late 1920s
Alexander Fleming discovered the very
first antibiotic known as penicillin and
when penicillin winning the mass
production it was wonderful it was
carrying diseases bacterial diseases
that previously were uncurable and not
long after World War two began and
wounded soldiers who in previous the
previous Wars may have died from
battlefield infections were being
treated with penicillin and they were
surviving and they were coming home and
so penicillin and and later antibiotics
were looked on as miraculous well
antibiotic sound wonderful so what's the
problem well the problem is now we
understand antibiotic resistance when
bacteria possess genetic variations that
allow them to survive the use of an
antibiotic in the picture the bacteria
and the left is resistant to an
antibiotic it multiplies and it's
offspring multiplies and over time an
entire population of bacteria are
resistant to an antibiotic and it's
really hard to treat and cure in this
person and so pretend here are bacteria
that you are infected with now the
letters just correspond to various genes
that they possess in their DNA
bacteria are living organisms and they
have DNA and genes and so one gene I
want to know is gene a the bacteria that
have gene a are going to be resistant to
the antibiotic we're going to use to
treat this person in a moment so here we
have the person taking their antibiotic
that went to the doctor they got a
prescription and now they're taking
their antibiotic and the antibiotic will
absorb into the bacterial cells well
let's zoom on in to this bacterial cell
that I've highlighted
and because this bacterial cell did not
have gene a little holes were popped in
the cell membrane and it died the
bacteria died and that's wonderful were
step closer to recovery so how do
antibiotics kill bacteria well as you
just saw one very sign of some type of
antibiotics will actually interfere with
the creation of the cell wall of the
bacteria and the bacteria will die other
antibiotics will interfere with their
ribosomes of the bacteria that prevents
the bacteria from creating needed
proteins and so therefore the bacteria
die and other antibiotics will actually
break apart the DNA of the bacteria thus
causing bacteria to die so when we come
back to our infected person notice how
the cells without the letter A have all
died now what about the two cells
remaining let's zoom on in for a closer
look at this cell right here and when we
do here we see it's DNA and earlier we
saw that this cell survived because it
had gene a a gene is a segment of DNA
and in this case let's pretend that gene
a allows the bacteria to produce a
transport protein so when the antibiotic
is absorbed into the bacterium the
transport protein lives up to its name
and transports the antibiotic right out
therefore never allowing the antibiotic
time to kill the bacteria this bacteria
is antibiotic resistant well another way
that some bacteria can survive in the
presence of an antibiotic again let's
pretend it has gene a is that gene might
allow the bacteria to produce enzymes
now as I've animated the enzyme as a
pair of scissors here and you can
imagine that when the bacteria absorbs
the antibiotic the enzymes will break
down the antibiotic thus allowing the
bacteria to survive this bacteria is and
of antibiotic resistant
and so when we come back to the two
surviving bacteria while bacteria also
multiply very rapidly and bacteria
reproduce asexually so when they
multiply they just copy themselves so
notice how their offspring are exact
duplicates the offspring also possess
gene a which will allow them to survive
in the presence of the antibiotic so
maybe you know a day later you're taking
the antibiotic again you're taking your
next dose of antibiotics as time goes by
however notice the only surviving
bacteria all possess gene a so these
bacteria are able to tolerate the the
antibiotic that you are taking to
hopefully get you better so what is
causing antibiotic resistance you know
the reason for the picture of Charles
Darwin is antibiotic resistance is a
great example of natural selection the
process were organisms with advantageous
traits are more likely to survive and
reproduce now Darwin didn't understand
anything about antibiotic resistance
because antibiotics weren't even
discovered until the 1920s but
antibiotic resistance is a great example
of the process outlined by Darwin it's
the survival of the fittest the stick
bacteria survive and produce similar
offspring those without the resistance
over time have all died from this
picture we can actually judge which
antibiotics you can use to cure somebody
in which you cannot and now this is what
I want to discuss is how do we read the
results of this picture which antibiotic
should be prescribed to this sick person
well let's go ahead and examine this so
here is a petri dish and what we're
doing is we're spreading bacteria that
we've collected from a sick person we're
spreading the bacteria all over the
petri dish and the bacteria will be
given the opportunity to grow all over
this petri dish
and what we're going to do next is we're
going to soak these little white cotton
disks each of them in a different kind
of antibiotic notice number one has been
soaked in penicillin number two has been
soaked in tetracycline number three has
been soaked in amoxicillin these are
three different kinds of antibiotics I
want to learn which antibiotic I can use
to treat this person so next again we
have our petri dish that we've just
spread bacteria all over we're now going
to add those cat knee discs that have
been treated with antibiotic one
antibiotic two antibiotic three and now
we're going to allow bacteria time to
grow
you know let's look at the petri dish
from above and now we're going to allow
bacteria time to grow and over time
we're going to start to see bacteria
growing all over this petri dish because
we spread the bacteria all over the
petri dish but how do we know which
antibiotics are working well let's look
at the results notice the areas
surrounding antibiotic number two
there's no bacteria growing this tells
me antibiotic number two is working the
bacteria are being killed in the area
directly surrounding antibiotic number
two same for antibiotic number three
there's no bacteria growing in the
vicinity of antibiotic number three this
tells me it's working the antibiotics
are killing the bacteria in the vicinity
this area is known as the zone of
inhibition by the way notice antibiotic
number one looks different however in
around antibiotic number one there are
still bacteria growing this tells me
antibiotic number one is not working
it's not working because the bacteria we
are resistant to antibiotic number one
so if this were an actual example then
we can prescribe antibiotic member two
or antibiotic member three to help treat
this person and end their bacterial
infection so here's an actual picture
notice there are nine different cotton
discs here and each of them has been
soaked entreated with a different
antibiotic so the bacteria covering this
petri dish is resistant to how many of
the nine tested antibiotics pause the
video if you want time to think about it
I'm going to go over the answer in three
two one
so in this picture I can see that the
bacteria are resistant to one two three
different times of antibiotics this is a
great example of a multi drug resistant
bacterial infection this is one
bacterial infection resistant to three
different kinds of antibiotics so what
can we all do to help lessen the rate of
antibiotic resistance well one of the
more important things we can do is to
use antibiotics under the care of a
doctor antibiotics are great for
treating bacterial infections but they
have no impact on viral infections so
just because you're coughing and you
have an infection does not mean you need
an antibiotic see your doctor and they
can prescribe the best course of
treatment also properly using
antibiotics
you know big day tomorrow I can't get
sick I'll take some antibiotics even
though I feel fine this is a real big
way to misuse antibiotics to just grab
leftover antibiotics that you might have
laying around in your medicine cabinet
at home only take antibiotics when
needed and as prescribed by a doctor and
when you do require the use of an
antibiotic make sure you finish your
prescribed dose if you're required to
take your antibiotics for three weeks
but after a week and a half you feel
fine and you feel better that doesn't
mean stop keep taking the last few days
of your prescription so you can be sure
of killing any last remaining pockets of
the bacteria that might have been
infecting you
and another way we can help to slow the
spread of antibiotic resistance is to
support organic farming you know a lot
of antibiotics are used in livestock so
by supporting organic farming you're
supporting farming without the use of
antibiotics and pesticides and
fertilizers and a whole bunch of
unnatural chemicals and so there you
have antibiotic resistance I want to
just leave this picture up here until
the very end of the video so pause if
you'd like to review six smart facts
about antibiotic use so thanks for
watching and please place your comments
in the box below